the gum bros my name is beer
welcome back dry up here I just had to
replay the oh no the room it's mom it's
in here let's use the flashlight
I had to replay the part with a last
night Italian woman thank you a woman or
not or maybe you are alright rumors
vomiting here I had to replay the Shane
sub part it was horrible Ruben's mom
hello Karen tea ribbon up even though I
know it's gonna [ __ ] happen you still
chop that bad up what she likes to suck
her own on okay I don't have any ammo I
have to Emma
mister plant what are you doing in there
converts lovely oh come on
those are dangerous I should not die
fine its serene or something
oh [ __ ] is after me oh [ __ ] you okay
lovely lovely absolutely fantastic I
don't want to die from that thing so
let's go there I need drugs and I need
it bad and then taking facebook pictures
I need a tape recorder or whatever I
need something annoying here yeah it's a
drugs why is there no drives when you
need it
huh come on drugs give me something all
right
just got to be careful what is this this
room is apartment ribbon coca-cola
lovely lovely lovely lovely okay good we
haven't what can you have two of them
really awesome my Tom um I was doing
something oh yeah I'm such an idiot
alright please we have some ammo now I
think we need more though it won't budge
stupid television right fine
I do have a gun now so
Oh No
why did they do that to me ah come on I
don't even know what that was I was a
woman named period everywhere
god damn it god back it's okay
stop complaining it's okay everything is
fine everything's chill here we got
control of the situation we're going in
here Oh
nipple guy do you ever [ __ ] quit
answer me
oh you can't ask me now cuz you're dead
bad excuse back up back up back up
you're not a Murloc get out of here okay
look at my health
seriously though look at my house what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] alright eras
dual-wielding time oh I am [ __ ] I knew
that was gonna happen I'm gonna have to
replay like hours now and this Shane so
part it's so scary I hate it I don't
even know anymore brush this part is
just terrifying
I don't all right run run run run run
oh I need that chainsaw guy I hate him
so much
alright now a little bug happen alright
fine
we can do this I can do this for Sparta
Lady Gaga Oprah would we go work and
that other girl all right let's do this
run run run run run around run and we've
gone down
oh come on ah that's okay that's okay
Reubens mom I love you I don't know how
I guess so okay whatever fire to
everything just we're in here we're in
trouble
we have to go in here yeah
mom are you okay no I'm not okay mom I'm
not okay alright let's go to spend some
see what friends and has to offer oh
yeah we've been in here what's there any
scary stuff here I don't remember the
motor controls
that's [ __ ] lovely alright now we
have some ammo I forgot about them
no I forgot about her son of a [ __ ] my
[ __ ] bad memory ok but we didn't
shake everything out I feel like we'd
really really need our ammo now brush we
need to man [ __ ] up and show that we can
do with this let's go here at one battle
that's fantastic alright this game is
just getting worse and worse isn't it ok
so we go down here got complete control
over situation as you shouldn't know we
don't know we don't know I'm sorry I
don't want to I want to be honest with
you bro oh come on if again Bam Bam Bam
you gotta get that got it
shoot it in the head or something they
die faster because I don't even know all
right sure there's another nipple guy
here okay you're not to marry luck I've
told him so many times so I you know it
okay mere luck I mean shoot it shoot it
oh you're together now idea okay let's
look if you had something or something
no he did it it just lives there all
night long and it's dark I know but I
want to be ready to reload my magazine
oh I have to reload it alright perfect
oh that one's not perfect it could have
been perfect if you think of how it was
perfect haha I did Reno all right any
more nipple guys
you [ __ ] hate you
I don't watch you I I would rape no I
wouldn't that's against love otherwise I
do okay
no rape jokes it's not funny it's not
funny okay what I can't go here are you
serious I went through hell for this no
no no no Senor Lita no not these days
there we go not this day sir
not this today no sir no sir mom
updating this on my facebook status okay
we're walking extremely fast too fast to
control to fast furious all right not
today [ __ ] that's what you get
bathtub and bluie I expected more of you
blue I didn't think he'd actually pull
off man Scott ball I gave him a man
given that look at my health look at my
[ __ ] health but it's been I don't
dare to do anything carelessly but
police bill
police bill did did someone try to rape
you policeman I think are you in trouble
police blink twice if you're in trouble
policing pretty bit I'm sorry I can't
understand it Roy is it Roy again but
it's bill please bill a tongue maybe
speaks for tongue do you understand me
do you understand what this means
no I don't either so it's [ __ ]
fantastic okay can you call these
numbers and stuff like that is there a
third if I don't within cell phone or
whatever oh look at this this is
beautiful I think the thing is I have so
little health I don't want to [ __ ] up I
just don't want to F up and we don't
have a tape recorder I don't want to
play it's just it's a shame Saul guy
he's scared I don't even know
can you go normally please thank you god
damn Simon that's your real name
I don't think it is look at this
beautiful sculpture oh I thought you
view it like this but I was watching his
[ __ ] I'm sorry Barry I'm sorry I said
I'm sorry your knife tonight
damn it all right sir
come on can't go there apparently okay
whatever
pop escorial quit the core we hate that
rhymed okay
weenie I'm just looking for a more stuff
right now what is this oh I can flip
that bird
I can flip the bird see when I am dead
there is island okay so I flipped the
bird I don't flip your little [ __ ]
there we go
what did I do what the hell am I doing
here am i moving him I'm moving the bird
that is amazing all right let's see what
we did with mr. birdie I don't trust him
he has an attitude and I don't like it
all right so what's up with this huh
bird tell me it's an ego oh you're an
eagle now and guess what I want it to be
me girly one out of the kid yes sir yes
sir I wanted to be one it is true all
right so you can move all of them maybe
there's something goodness aah
wasting my animal [ __ ]
I am hey doggie doggie
are you a lion or a bad bad why are they
called lamb
all right so what did I do
horsey horsey horsey it's just a puzzle
horsey I'm not very good at Jennifer
they doing anything
oh there it is press it I dare you
horsey did you write this
no I didn't I Fred I love you what
passage I tell you what
no I don't Boise I don't know what I
feel about it do it back okay okay
anything horsey
huorchi what did i do horsey
Oh kindly the last lion is up here why
do you keep falling down buddy come on
you can do better than that
look at this taking photos okay so let's
move this one there we go
and with Charlotte ladies and gentlemen
all right it was in the right place I
don't know like what's going on up here
why is everyone making a mess is
everyone moving out of this place I
would make sense though I don't want my
watch it's a tacky
what should I drop
I can't I'm dropping the baton I'm sorry
I'm dropping it I'm taking this baby
right here
oh snap each new Oh Oh baby oh my sweet
baby be gentle with me hahaha
all right final ism' Oh [ __ ] why you
said oh she camped out to Doris and
didn't do that's good for her absolutely
splendid for her I'm really happy for
her that's the son of a [ __ ]
I can snipe that out
sniping that [ __ ] okay so we're gonna go
over here say and then we're gonna end
the episode like and favorite if you
enjoyed subscribe to become a bro today
and I'll see you next
what have it radio I try to make what
the hell is that
oh no oh so I'm gonna do something oh no
I'm running funny I'm running for I'm
running for it you see why where the
hell did he go oh he's after me that
means that it's okay it's gonna know